this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill as the world grapples
to eliminate fossil fuels from our
energy diet electric cars have seen an
incredible boom over the past few years
last year over 1 million electric cars
were sold around the world the number of
Nissan Leafs Tesla's and other electric
vehicles in circulation worldwide is now
more than 3 million and while there are
many brands of electric car to choose
from there are only two choices when it
comes to powering electric vehicles fuel
cells or batteries both produce
electricity to drive electric motors
eliminating the pollution and
inefficiencies of the fossil fuel
powered internal combustion engine both
hydrogen and electricity for batteries
can be produced from low or zero carbon
sources including renewable energy like
solar and wind and therefore both are
being pursued by carry manufacturers and
researchers as the possible future of
electric vehicles however a great debate
is being waged by supporters of each
technology Elon Musk has called hydrogen
fuel cell technology incredibly dumb
claiming they're more of a marketing
ploy for automakers than a long-term
solution
in contrast Japan has announced its
intention to become the world's first
hydrogen society with the Japanese
government and the auto industry working
together to introduce a hundred and
sixty hydrogen stations and 40,000 fuel
cell vehicles by March 2021 so which is
actually better at first glance hydrogen
seems like an extremely clever way to
power a car compressed hydrogen has a
specific energy of nearly 40,000 watt
hours per kilogram lithium-ion batteries
at best have a specific energy of just
278 watt hours per kilogram but most
fall around 167 that's 236 times as much
energy per kilogram for hydrogen and
because of its energy density and
lightweight nature compressed hydrogen
and fuel cells can power cars for
extended ranges without adding much
weight which as we saw in our last video
is a gigantic roadblock for
incorporating the technology into the
aviation industry the designers of
electric vehicles are caught in a
catch-22 with energy density and range
each extra kilogram of battery waste to
increase range requires extra structural
weighs heavier brakes a
torque motor and in turn more batteries
to carry around this extra mass this
weight compounding limits how far a
battery powered vehicle can travel until
new technology can help reduce the
weight of the batteries for hydrogen
vehicles this weight compounding is not
an issue additionally a hydrogen fuel
cell vehicle can be refueled in under
five minutes
where a battery-powered electric vehicle
like a Tesla Model S takes over three
hours to fully recharge when looking at
the range and refuel times hydrogen can
offer you can see why some care
manufacturers are investing in this
technology on the face of it hydrogen is
a clear winner but it falls behind when
we start considering the end to end
production process while both batteries
and hydrogen fuel cells are both forms
of electricity storage the costs differ
drastically fully charging a Tesla Model
3 with a 75 kilowatt hour battery cost
between ten and twelve dollars depending
where you live with a rated range of 500
kilometers that's between 2 and 2.4 cent
per kilometer a great price in a
previous video I visited a petrol
station that introduced a hydrogen pump
fed by its own on-site production
facility which used off-peak electricity
to produce hydrogen the hydrogen from
the station cost $85 to fill a 5
kilogram tank of the Toyota Mirai zhan
site which had a range of 480 kilometers
that 17.7 cent per kilometer 8 times the
price and here lies the problem
hydrogen simply requires more energy to
produce to understand the economic
viability of hydrogen let's dig deeper
into the production process before any
hydrogen vehicle can hit the road you
first need to produce the hydrogen but
hydrogen is not a readily available
energy source
even though hydrogen is the most
abundant element in the universe it is
usually stored in water hydrocarbons
such as methane and other organic matter
one of the challenges of using hydrogen
as an energy storage mechanism comes
from being able to efficiently extract
it from these compounds in the United
States the majority of hydrogen is
produced through process called steam
reforming steam reforming is the process
of combining high temperature steam with
natural gas to extract hydrogen while
steam reforming is the most common
method of industrial hydrogen production
it requires a good deal of heat
is wildly inefficient hydrogen produced
by steam reforming actually has less
energy than the natural gas that the
steam reforming began with and while
hydrogen fuel cells themselves don't
produce pollution this process does so
if we want to assume a future scenario
with as little carbon emission as
possible this method won't cut it
another method to produce hydrogen is
electrolysis separating the hydrogen out
of water using an electric current while
the electricity needed for this process
can be provided by renewable sources it
requires more energy input than steam
reforming you end up losing 30 percent
of the energy from the original energy
you put in from the renewables when you
carry out electrolysis so we are sitting
at 70 percent energy efficiency from
hydrogen fuel cells
if traditional electrolysis is used
before the car even starts its engine a
slightly more efficient method of
producing hydrogen is polymer exchange
membrane electrolysis using this method
energy efficiencies can reach up to 80
percent with the added benefit of being
produced on-site which we will get to in
a moment
but this is still a 20% loss of energy
from the original electricity from the
renewables some experts say the
efficiency of PM electrolysis is
expected to reach 82 to 86 percent
before 2030 which is a great improvement
but still well short of the batteries
charging efficiency at 99 percent a 19
percent difference in production costs
doesn't explain the difference in cost
yet so where else are we losing energy
the next hurdle in getting hydrogen fuel
cell vehicles on the road is the
transport and storage of the pure
hydrogen if we assume the hydrogen is
produced on-site like it was for this
petrol station then we eliminate one
energy sink but the cost of storage is
just as problematic hydrogen is
extremely low density as a gas and
liquid and so in order to achieve
adequate energy density we have to
increase its actual density we can do
this in two ways
we can compress the hydrogen to 790
times atmospheric pressure but that
takes energy about 13% of the total
energy content of the hydrogen itself
alternatively we can turn hydrogen into
liquid cryogenically the advantage of
hydrogen liquification is that
biogenic hydrogen tank is much lighter
than a tank that can hold pressurized
hydrogen but again hydrogen's physical
properties means hydrogen is harder to
liquefy than any other gas except helium
hydrogen is liquefied by reducing its
temperature to minus 250 degrees Celsius
with an efficiency loss of 40 percent
once you factor in the added weight of
the refrigerators and the refrigeration
itself so pressurization is a better
option at a 13% energy loss once the
hydrogen is produced and compressed to a
liquid or gas a viable hydrogen
infrastructure requires that hydrogen be
able to be delivered from where it's
produced to the point of end use such as
a vehicle refueling station where the
hydrogen is produced can have a big
impact on the cost and best method of
delivery for example a large centrally
located hydrogen production facility can
produce hydrogen at a lower cost because
it is producing more but it cost more to
deliver the hydrogen because the point
of use is further away in comparison
distributed production facilities
produce hydrogen on-site so delivery
costs are relatively low but the cost to
produce the hydrogen is likely to be
higher because the production volumes
are less while there are some
small-scale on-site hydrogen production
facilities being installed at refueling
pumps such as the station mentioned in
my last hydrogen video until this
infrastructure is widespread we have to
assume that the majority of hydrogen is
being transported by truck or pipeline
where we know that the energy losses can
range from 10 percent up to 40 percent
in comparison assuming that the
electricity we use for charging the
batteries comes from completely
renewable resources we just have to
consider the transmission losses in the
grid
using the United States grid as a
reference for typical grid losses the
average loss is only 5% so in the best
case scenario for hydrogen using the
most efficient means of production and
transport we lose twenty percent of
energy during p.m. electrolysis and
around 13 percent for compression and
storage amounting to a 33 percent loss
in other systems this could be as much
as 56% for battery power up to this
point we've lost just 6% to the grid and
recharging bringing our best case
efficiency difference to 27% and our
worst case to 50% the next stage of
powering electric vehicles is what is
called a tank to wheel
conversion efficiency for hydrogen fuel
vehicles once the hydrogen is in the
tank
it must be reconverted into electric
power this is done via a fuel cell which
essentially works like a PM electrolyzer
but in Reverse in a PM fuel cell
hydrogen gas flows through channels to
an anode where a catalyst causes the
hydrogen molecules to separate into
protons and electrons
once again the membrane only allows
protons to pass through it while
electrons flow through an external
circuit to the cathode this flow of
electrons is the electricity that is
used to power the vehicles electric
motors if the fuel cell is powered with
pure hydrogen it has the potential to be
around 60% efficient with most of the
wasted energy lost to heat like hydrogen
fuel cells batteries come within
efficiencies and energy losses the grid
provides AC current while the batteries
store the charge in DC so to convert AC
to DC we need a charger using the Tesla
Model S as an example it's peak charger
efficiency is around 92% the Tesla Model
S runs on AC motors therefore it to
convert the DC current supplied by the
batteries to AC current an inverter has
to be used to at an efficiency of
roughly 90%
additionally lithium-ion batteries can
lose energy due to leakage a good
estimate for the charging efficiency of
a lithium-ion battery is 90% all of
these factors combined lead to a total
efficiency of around 75% however
hydrogen fuel cell vehicles have some of
these same inefficiencies any kind of
electrolysis requires DC current and
therefore a rectifier will be required
to convert the AC current from the grid
to DC the conversion efficiency here is
92% we also need to convert the DC
current produced by the fuel cell to AC
current to power the motor through an
inverter with an efficiency of 90%
finally the efficiency of the motor must
be considered for both the fuel cell and
battery powered vehicles currently this
is around 90 to 95 percent for both
which is amazing when you consider that
internal combustion engines running on
petrol have an efficiency of only around
20 to 30 percent if we add up all these
inefficiencies and compare current
generation batteries to the best and
worst case scenario for current gen
hydrogen we can see how they measure up
even with the best-case-scenario not
taking into account and
transports you to on-site production an
assuming very high electrolysis
efficiency of 80% and assuming a high
fuel cell efficiency of 80% hydrogen
still comes out at less than half the
efficiency the worst-case scenario is
even worse off so while you may be able
to go further on one Phillip of hydrogen
in your fuel cell vehicle over a
battery-powered electric vehicle the
cost that is needed to deliver that one
Phillip would be astronomically higher
compared to charging batteries due to
these energy losses and inefficiencies
based on our worst case scenario we
could expect the cost per kilometer to
be about 3.5 times greater for hydrogen
but as we saw earlier it's actually 8
times the price so additional cost of
production unrelated to efficiencies are
obviously a play the cost of
construction of the facility is 1 and
the profit the station will take from
the sale is another 4 now these
inefficiencies and costs are driving the
market where most investment and
research is going into battery-powered
electric vehicles so which wins both are
equally more green than internal
combustion engines assuming equal
renewable resources are used to power
them
fuel cells allow for fast Phillip times
and long ranges a big advantage but
battery-powered vehicles might catch
open range by the time there are enough
hydrogen stations to make fuel cell
vehicles viable while fuel cells are
efficient relative to combustion engines
they are not as efficient as batteries
they may make more sense for operation
disconnected from the grid or as we saw
in our last video using hydrogen for
planes actually could make a lot of
sense but once again that's a topic for
another video for now battery-powered
electric vehicles seem to be the
sensible choice going forward in the
quest for pollution free consumer
transport as battery powered cars become
more common we're also starting to see
self-driving cars become the norm if the
job of the driver is slowly automated
away and consumers have a bunch of free
time to read or watch online video it
may be wise to use that opportunity to
start learning new skills and skill
share is a great place to do it you
could take this course and Photoshop for
beginners and learn a skill that has
helped this channel immensely you may
have noticed we introduced the new
thumbnail design for the channel this
was done in part because the channel
views were trending downwards for the
past two months despite putting extra
effort into production
we needed to rethink our strategy for
branding and I felt the blueprint
strength Placido was easily recognizable
as mine but they also look so similar
it's difficult to tell when there is a
new video out so we got to work in
Photoshop to use the strengths of the
blueprint design and build on its
weaknesses and we came up with this
transitioning effect taking designs to
reality which i think fits perfectly
with the theme of the channel we saw
immediate effects with the views on our
last video jumping 80% compared to our
past to mow the average this is the
power of illustration and you can learn
how to use software like Photoshop and
illustrator on Scotia these days you can
teach yourself pretty much any skill
online and Scotia is a fantastic place
to do it with over 20,000 classes
ranging from animation electronics
programming and much more the classes
follow a clear learning curve so you can
just click and watch without having to
curate your own learning experience a
Premium Membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 1,000 people to
sign up with this link will get their
first two months for free so ask
yourself right now
what skill have you been putting off
learning what project have you been
dreaming of completing but you aren't
sure if you have the skills to do it why
not start right now and sign up the
skill share using the link below to get
your first two months for free you have
nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain as usual thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Twitter Facebook
discord server subreddit and Instagram
pages are below I'm about to do a Q&A on
the subject matter of this video on my
Instagram stories so if you're
interested in having some of your
questions answered the link for that is
below